I realized that the Russians are just
idiots and they're so stupid those whose
life is soaked in chibous have no chance
to conquer us I've lived in this
building all those Pushkin poems all
those monuments to Lenin pave the way
for a Russian tank they demanded that we
sing the songs which they liked such as
fellow officers and others
I returned in 54 days
the screaming wouldn't stop we have now
felt what freedom and liberty are really
like you have no idea how long we've
been waiting are you really from Ukraine
yes
because we ukrainians are united by Fate
it was a surprise for the moscovites but
they followed the Russian warship and
it's okay to be in the basement the main
thing is that we're alive and well we
have no water even now we have no
central heating but we also have no
muscovites here that's why we're so
happy because they mess with Ukraine
foreign
[Music]
we must not forget to take a picture
here later
ladies and gentlemen we came to Harrison
past Sean obeyaca
Entry Road is in good condition thank
you Russian bastards for not ruining
everything
public minibuses are in operation pretty
cool that's just unbelievable Russia is
here to stay forever
Russia is to stay here forever
[Music]
how did the deoccupation take place here
you were directly involved in those
events you hoisted the first Ukrainian
flag in stanislav village and here as
well
together with the 28th Brigade
I hosted our Ukraine flag at my house
[Music]
[Applause]
I didn't expect this to happen to be
honest my eyes were filled with tears as
well it was hard yes but we did the same
job I made a lot of friends and we all
helped each other
no one here has ever supported Russia we
have always lived here everything was
fine for us is there anything written on
the flag yes the flag was signed by
people who were with us those who took
part in the events
I also left my signature on it my call
sign is study so I left it there as my
signature
what is your personal story you said you
were in a special police force unit
right
there were those amongst the Bearcat
members in fact who fled to the Crimea
and Russia to be honest I believe that
those people who went over to the side
of the Invaders I'm not going to judge
them why not because God will judge them
people have to decide for themselves
somehow in my view if you live at your
own home that's your place keep living
there we should not change our native
country but this is my opinion that's
how it is in my view if you live in
Ukraine then keep living in Ukraine tell
us about that moment when you enter the
city Square here to be honest when we
entered the square people were confused
they couldn't understand what was
happening they asked us are you really
from Ukraine I said yes we are they
asked Are You Soldiers we answered we
are indeed they demand
okay we believe you go on then and we
hoisted the flag
[Applause]
[Music]
Nation
you went through the council didn't you
and weren't you afraid that it was mine
yeah yeah we went up the stairs to the
fourth floor and voices the flag God
damn it it was so joyful the people were
very welcoming I'm so grateful to all
the people
[Applause]
[Music]
were hugging and kissing us they were so
happy I'm so happy that most of the
people in here son are in fact Ukraine
supporters
sorry for the story that's okay these
are emotions I see there is already
graffiti with zalushny yeah
more and more Ukrainian symbols are
appearing of course people were already
beginning to understand people are
supporting honestly the joy is when you
are home and you're alive and happy
don't hesitate to kiss and to hug our
service men and women Ukraine did not
expect to take a hit like this
the Invaders thought that Ukraine would
easily be captured no way not when the
air the land and the trees help us
everything helps us people are praying
for us this is the most important thing
[Music]
you're the one who was giving an
interview in English in the first days
of Liberation yes yes just because I
know English and this was the first time
that that CNN live and Sky News got here
and for some reason the Ukrainian media
were not allowed the foreign journalists
came and asked who speaks English I gave
an interview and someone in the crowd
who as we say understands language like
a dog which means they understand but
can't say anything commented oh very
well said mate and the journalists also
liked my speech finally liberated that
we are free because now we have no
electricity in the city no water no
Central Supply heating no mobile
connection no internet connection but we
have no Russians and I'm extremely happy
of that we can survive anything
but we are free the Ukrainian word could
stop in English it translates as [__]
Russians I wasn't allowed to say [__]
so I had to say just Russians therefore
the phrase at the time sounded like this
we have no electricity we have no water
even now we have no central heating we
have no mobile network but there are no
moscowites here and that's why people
are so happy
in the first days there were
celebrations here people were coming out
and finding out the news actually this
phrase became famous it triggered the
moscobite's response and they started to
claim that I was either an American spy
or the head of a special forces from
cave finally liberated that we are
friends
created the full scale Invasion start
for you initially as I was saying
they're most likely there would be no
Invasion but if it were to happen if
they were to start an invasion then they
would lose I was confident that there
wouldn't be any Invasion because I
thought that they were just trying to
intimidate Us by by moving their army
around and yet they started the invasion
and they are losing it now step by step
they're being pushed out the north of
karaki region and the north of the
herzon region as you can see have
already been deoccupied as for my
experience during the occupation I I
participated in rallies in fact the
rallies ended at some point because
people realized that it was impossible
to oppose the military any further what
was the resistance like after that then
there was graffiti on the city walls
there are a lot of yellow ribbons yeah
yeah ribbons they are also pro-ukrainian
slogans of course some of those have
appeared after de-occupation yet many
were made during the occupation have you
ever talked to Russian occupiers I tried
to avoid them
those Russian bastards were wandering
around everywhere
but still there were some really crowded
places and we knew where to go to to
avoid them
well
you know other people talk to them but
but they disgusted me so I try to avoid
them for some reason they were most
interested in people's garages they
would drive into a garage neighborhood
pull out all the gates with a tractor
and just loot everything could they
possibly be looking for civilian cars I
think they were looking for weapons
maybe cars too where they checking the
apartments well well they came to my
block of flats but we're walking around
less cocky they just came knocked on
everyone's door I was at home but I was
sitting and thinking well and who might
that be if they break in then I'll go
and say oh you know I was asleep and I
just couldn't hear anything they just
knocked on the door I didn't open it and
they went away did they try to track
down those who were at the rallies of
course they did they were most
interested in three categories of people
those were pro-ukrainian activists that
is those who were at rallies and those
who organized them the second category
was those who were connected with the
Ukrainian Army in some way that is they
could just be family members or they
could be people who received weapons or
could have received them and the third
category was just rich people because
they could be deceived and robbed these
days when we start speaking with people
in the liberated territories we find
that they all speak Ukrainian even
though quite a few people spoke mostly
Russian before the full scan Invasion
this is no longer so what about you the
same thing I still remember and
understand Russian but I'm trying to
speak more Ukrainian now why is this
happening why do you think this is so
important well this is happening because
everyone here has seen enough of
moscobytes eight months it's a long time
it's a huge Chasm
people who I used to know consistently
supported the Russian World
by voting for the pro-russian political
party in the early days of the war they
even were afraid they were afraid to
openly say the supported moscovites they
were afraid to say finally you came
we've been waiting for you for eight
years and so on they felt a different
attitude from the other City residents
they felt that they were in the minority
and that the others were very hostile to
them I asked are you glad that the
Russians are here no we aren't we didn't
want it to be like this they didn't want
moscowites to come here with weapons
they just wanted some sort of a friendly
relationship and then at some point they
even started to refer to the Ukrainian
troops as our troops that is even during
the occupation such thoughts appeared
now after the liberation of course we've
come out of the underground oh the
referendum you might be interested in
the Russian referendum I guess
yeah this is an incredible story
actually it was held for five days they
put up their booths in the market in the
in the central part of the market
yeah some people voted I I have to admit
but 80 of them were old women 15 percent
were old men
and five percent they were they were low
lives
that is these were the major categories
but there were still not many of these
people and what was the result well the
result you already know 146 percent of
the population supported Germany and
Russia and becoming the moscowitz land
here and now but it was impossible to
even check how many people voted in here
that is there were percentages but there
was no indication of the quantity I
think there was I watched the video and
it may be difficult to find it now it
was from their propaganda Channel vtv
plus namely broadcasting in the Carson
region they took it over and made it
work for them according to that video
when 12 of ballots were counted in the
so-called kerasan People's Republic this
was 660 votes that is 100 percent is six
thousand before the war one million two
hundred thousand people lived in our
region so the Russians themselves
revealed the information that very few
people came to to vote in the referendum
there were times when there was no
internet we had to watch their moronic
propaganda TV and sometimes when you
watch intently there are such
interesting things you can sometimes see
the truth sometimes it sticks out none
of those who were promoting the voting
came to our district that is it's a huge
area but there was no voting at the time
we all agreed to remain in our homes and
not to let them in should they knock on
the door they didn't even come to the
apartments so in the entire huge City
District people stayed home just as we
did and they didn't go to the center or
any other part saw the city well the
Russians simply made a nice TV picture
for Their audience and that was it
that's all they really needed not a
referendum they organized the voting in
a handful of places filmed it and that's
it
in those places where it was more
difficult for people to hide the
occupiers could walk with there were
videos on which they walked with assault
rifles we were prepared for that as well
but no one came they held a referendum
very quickly three days before the event
they decided they would hold it first
that stupid stem usov the deputy of the
local occupation Administration was
insisting that there will be no
referendum why well no one will believe
it anyways that was when Russians had no
such intentions but then something
changed the directive changed and so did
their plans and the so-called voting was
carried out that was a real shame where
did you work I work at the market
therefore all the time I could hear what
the people's mood was like and what was
happening and in general I'm a good
listener so I watched and listened
carefully a lot of people went to the
regions controlled by Ukraine when it
was still possible to get to the vasilia
Village this was the people's popular
route
than even those who left her son through
the moscowites territory left via Crimea
still tried to go to Europe or first to
get to Georgia and then to Europe no
matter how they were leaving few stayed
in the mosquito bites territory but not
a lot I don't think mostly those who
collaborated right collaborators those
who those who are more sympathetic to
the regime it's true that some people
were scared we were all scared this
mariopal Syndrome has been with us for a
long time people were worried that as
the Ukrainian forces Advanced there
would be severe terrible fighting I knew
the moscovites were scumbags now with
this full-scale Invasion I find out that
they are just idiots and they're really
stupid what I didn't know was that the
moscovites are such cowards I wouldn't
have believed that they would run away
in just a day and a half somehow I was
just confident that they would be
holding their positions but they
disappeared in just a day and a half on
the 9th of November in the evening the
electricity and internet disappeared and
on the 11th of November it turned out
that we were liberated I just saw two
cars that passed with Ukrainian Flags I
was so surprised thinking guys aren't
you just a little bit too brave isn't it
a bit too early maybe it's with waiting
a bit as it turned out it was no longer
risky they knew that the city had been
liberated we waved the flag of Ukraine
which was about 200 meters long finally
the occupation is over
I was in Houston from the first day to
the last day of its occupation I went to
our peaceful rallies
what did you get to the first rallies
how did they even start
I went to the city square and
saw that people were gathering I knew
several activists and they told me what
time and what days we would go in the
first days up to 5 000 people came here
especially on Saturdays and Sundays
there were many Ukrainian flags and
slogans
we sang Hey Hey rise up and buy right
our songs
everybody
people were singing the national anthem
of Ukraine and at first the Russians
were just watching us
every day it was getting worse arrests
gunshots stun grenades and tear gas were
used
foreign
[Applause]
and every day there were fewer fewer and
fewer people how long did it last all
this lasted for almost a month
[Applause]
so there's still people who tried to put
up some resistance do you know about
such cases
I call her The Iron Lady
she has the people's Bureau of Ukraine
title and as an honorary citizen of our
city she was going to the rallies even
during the occupation
she had an office for a volunteer Center
there were a lot of documents a lot of
flags and even Molotov cocktails during
the occupation I was helping her rescue
at least something from there
unfortunately the Russians later
captured her and as she said they put a
black bag over her head beat hers
undressed her and threatened that they
would cut off her breasts
asking for the names of the activists
but she told them I don't know anybody
even if I knew I wouldn't tell you
anything they beat her up badly and
threw her in the basement
she rolled down the stairs losing
Consciousness she is 70 years old
they thought that she was already dead
so they threw the body out
she survived and got to the hospital
I'm not sure if she had been lying at
her home
for the last three days or if she's
still in the hospital I can't reach her
she read poems by Tara and sang
Ukrainian songs at the rallies yes at
the rallies and over there there were
the arashes standing and watching when
they didn't like something they started
shooting in the air and throwing Sun
grenades did any of the locals joined
the rushes when they were still standing
there and you were here
was there any pro-russian meeting the
occupiers were afraid to have some kind
of pro-russian meeting because there
were so many more of us say we could
sweep them away in the early days there
were only servicemen they for example
just watched us and turned on the sun
and other Soviet songs to shout over us
that's how it was and then probably the
Ross Guardia police force arrived which
then whose job is to tackle unruly
civilians exactly it was getting harder
and harder every day and then there were
no people coming anymore because when
there were 5 000 or at least 500
protesters this was more or less okay
but when there were only about 40 or 50
people police could easily grab them and
take them to the pre-trial Detention
Center
I try to take photos and shoot videos
because those were historic moments in
our city twice I had to run away from
the young Hooligans who served the
occupiers I'm a local resident I knew
the route and the surroundings I was
lucky enough to escape
did they manage to capture you or no
they came to me and asked what are you
filming I realized that if they took my
phone now I would be arrested for a
variety of reasons the first time I ran
and I was able to escape through the
yards
then I started taking videos from the
trolley bus once at the bus stop near
the Central department store I was
filming people who were queuing to get
Russian passports
[Music]
and when I got off the bus a young man
followed me he said oh man are you
filming again you managed to escape last
time I pretended to be a fool I'm not
filming anything I was just checking
what time it was I got back to the
trolley bus and got away
she also got on the truck same trolley
busy and when we got to the next stop he
went to the driver so that he wouldn't
open the door
but the driver opened the door and I
jumped out
I was able to escape and take another
bus he didn't chase me for too long
he is 17 or 18 years old and he was
probably not as bold since he was alone
for about two or three days I wasn't
filming anything and then I started
again
but from inside the public transport
what did you manage to film yeah what
kind of videos
what are the key events that happened
I filmed our rallies when Alina was
singing and reciting poetry
what the situation was like in the early
days and how many people were there I
made videos however marching and how he
stopped a dozen armored vehicles there
were so many people walking down the
street that they couldn't drive through
they just stood there and were shouting
rashes or fascist to them
[Applause]
one of the occupiers lost his temper and
opened fire into the air we went to the
park of glory and held another rally
there
a car went past and its PA announced
Mass rallies are prohibited
during the occupation across the bridge
there were checkpoints before the island
towards the corbelline district and they
were checking all the trolley buses
buses and cars going to the island or
leaving it this
is around the 6th or 7th of November
they disappeared
yes every day there were fewer and fewer
vehicles
there were not so many military
personnel anymore the 9th of November
was the last day when I saw some
soldiers at the market before that they
were buying clothes in the store
carrying bags of clothes and buying warm
clothes at the market and on the 10th of
November when I came out I didn't see
anyone anymore
well I did not and then on the 11th of
November we started celebrating our
independence the key thing is that we
are free we can walk in peace talk to
each other peacefully and live the same
way we did in free Ukraine have you
always spoken Ukrainian no I haven't
but in the middle of the occupation step
by step I started speaking Ukrainian a
friend of mine who lives in America with
whom I played football at the labinovski
tournament
said we need to communicate in Ukrainian
and I gave him my word that from that
day I would communicate with him in
Ukrainian so now I try to communicate
more and more in ukrainians
you speak well yeah and I suppose it's
important to return to your nation's
native language
yes it is so that as many people as
possible communicate in Ukrainian and
Russians won't have a picture that there
is a Russian World here as they say
to stay here forever as they wrote
forever huh and yet they followed that
Russian warship 24th of October your son
there was a monument to Alexander
took it away along with stolen toilets
and sinks
on the 6th of October the occupiers
organized holidays for children they
took them to Anapa and Crimea for
recuperation free of charge
then they showed videos of children
playing being happy and eating and there
were no explosions and then they
announced now it is dangerous in here
son so we cannot return the children
back here so those parents who wish to
reunite with their children have to come
to them instead some parents went to be
with their children
they stayed together for maybe a week
and then they were told
as the next group will be arriving soon
you need to go to Russia
we will give you a place to stay there
the children will be happy
so in fact they kidnapped people they
did they also took children from
orphanages I have a neighbor who is a
principal of an orphanage
he said that the members of the staff
managed to hide several children but
unfortunately the Russians took most of
them away
and not only from that particular
orphanage but also from Kindergartens
the Russians knew that if they took the
kids they could do whatever they wanted
with them
why do you think Russia will fail
why will it fail
almost everyone who wants to take over
someone else's territory loses
because people are defending their land
especially when it's a sovereign
territory
and as I said before
those whose life is soaked in cheap
booze
have no chance to conquer us
thank you so much
[Music]
first thing we met with the local
celebrities
the video with one of them got millions
of viewers because it was recorded
during the first days of the liberation
of her son
quite unexpectedly
we met that guy again in the city center
it's quite amusing that he works at the
market
I'm such an ordinary guy and that older
man whom we met
he has fantastic stories about the
resistance
so this was actually the resistance
during the first weeks of the occupation
all the video footage that we saw about
the resistance in the Hearthstone was in
particular with his participation
and have you kept all of these videos
yes I have photos and videos from the
first to the last day and until today I
transferred them to a flash drive but I
did my best to preserve them
the man gave us two flash drives
I have them right here
these flash drives actually contain his
rallies his videos of all those rallies
you see there is a New York keychain on
this flash drive it's there because as
he told us he lived in New York
and I think that this is great material
that we should bring back and archive in
general for everyone who has any
materials from the occupation we are
ready to receive them from you and
archive them so that other
documentarians can use it
together with docu days we make a war
archive project and we archive materials
about everything that happened during
the hostilities
therefore we will be grateful for any
content
we will now record an interview with
autumn
in 2014 he was internally displaced from
luhransk when fighting broke out there
worked in the theater named after Nikola
coolish and did not cooperate with the
collaborators in the theater
we'll have a chat and he'll tell us
about his experience
what was happening to the theater during
the occupation initially the Invaders
didn't show interest in the theater they
they didn't even care about it as a
space
then the theater started working when
news about the so-called referendum
began to roll out sometime around the
second half of August
and the first performances were shown to
the occupational Administration for
approval just like back in the Soviet
days
they were very low quality kind of like
amateur performances not a single poster
was hung in the city not a single ticket
was put on sale not a single person came
out and said
I saw the performance it was really
beautiful were you doing anything to
preserve cultural life I mean you
weren't just
well it was hard to do anything related
to culture the priority was finding
something to eat
there was no such thing as a as a
concert front during the occupation
but at the same time uncle hirscher was
riding around blasting Ukrainian music
yes we saw him and always supported him
tell me how's Carson doing
yes it's tough in here son
the situation with money is Harsh
there's no way to get cash
but we're surviving and waiting
we are waiting for victory
[Music]
are waiting for our guys to come
glory to Ukraine glory to the heroes the
first few months we were living at the
local Cotton Factory
City life was revolving around the
markets the Central Market the Harrison
Cotton Factory and the schumensky market
so of course we used to see Uncle
horisha all the time we stayed really
quiet I wasn't even playing the trumpet
but on November 13th I went out to to
play the national anthem on the square
I realized I might not be able to play
it physically because it's hard when you
when you haven't taken an instrument in
your hands for nine months and suddenly
you want to play it
fuel but I had enough strength did it
work out yeah it turned out well
[Music]
why will the Russia lose
you know I I think it's inherent in
their DNA I mean I mean please just take
a look at those people they swallow
absolutely everything that they're being
fed
ex damn look at this place wow
the centralized water supply is down
[Music]
foreign
Mercy now
we don't know that or perhaps he got
away
maybe maybe they had left a
pharmaceutical business bringing
medicines and other products
as far as I know but I'm not 100 sure
maybe they left us a whole family I
haven't seen them were there many
collaborators amongst the educators
is that okay
100 people maybe 350 including part-time
doctors who conducted practical classes
for students and polyclinics and
hospitals some Educators even weren't to
work in the Russian Department of Health
[Music]
cooperation encouraged
during which they offered everyone who
wanted to stay to work at a college at
the Russian one
you had to write a formal request for
that if you hadn't then you weren't
allowed to come to college anymore and
that's all so you had to go to the
principal ask for permission and after
that only you could come back and pick
up some things and did the educational
process begin
was it conducted somehow uh yes they're
starting to work on the first of
September as far as I know they
recruited students for the first year in
nursing
paramedical and Dental Programs
what was education like during the
occupation
lots of teachers refused to work
occupiers had problems so there were a
lot of newcomers apparently no one left
the schools as far as I know the
occupiers tried to of course impose
their own perception of everything
what was happening with Ukrainian
textbooks oh our Librarians thank God
hid all of the Ukrainian books because
well anything could happen as you know
they could have just been burned and now
we're taking them out and starting all
over again so they survived the
occupation right they survived the
occupation thank God how did you greet
our guys
my mom and I went to a cafe where we
could charge our phones we had some
coffee and on the way back we met a
neighbor who said do you know that our
boys are in the city I said no he said
yeah and I responded until I see it for
myself I won't believe it at all
so I walked through the Freedom Square
there was already a Ukrainian flag
hoisted and Ukrainian songs were playing
I'm not a Sentimental person but I am
burst into tears even now I'm sorry then
on Saturday I was walking the Georgian
Legion was there God such great guys oh
my God I was asking them if they needed
any food some tomato some Jam or
something else and they kept saying we
don't need anything and he said just
take it we got to celebrate on Saturday
we have these elderly neighbors with
whom we occasionally get together even
during the occupation life continued we
were celebrating birthdays other stuff
having barbecues and they used to say
don't be loud so this time we asked can
we be loud and they said hell yeah and
be loud that's it our army is in the
city we can do anything we want yeah
that's
my heart is happy I finally have the
desire to live to breathe when I was
walking around carouson during those
eight months it seemed as if there were
no people in the city and now I go to
the main Square I'm stunned wow such a
huge number of cars and people around
were people afraid to even leave the
house we were leaving our houses but
walking like like this it was so scary
and Soldiers with v signs gosh no it's
all right it's great
now we're also waiting for the Left Bank
of the city to be liberated
and for the Crimean bridge to be blown
up completely
completely so that nothing remains of it
and we're also waiting for that
jellyfish that came with the bridge to
disappear from the as of sea once and
for all now we can hear explosions in
the background this is such a routine
thing that no one even pays attention to
it anymore
we don't pay attention at all especially
during the occupation you know something
funny when the Russian air defense
systems were active here and everyone's
standing up and waiting for it to be hit
and they're like oh it did yay
I mean which part of Ukraine is not
getting attacked I have students in
leviv and Vinita and Kiev and everywhere
else and they ride me and I ask where
are you they answer we're in the
basement well okay let it be in the
basement most importantly they're alive
and well why will Russia suffer defeat
because it's dealing with Ukraine
you better not better not be with
ukrainians at all a German or some other
politician
Otto von Bismarck so I don't remember he
said the Mind cannot understand Russia
it's very difficult to understand them
seriously during the occupation we were
walking around the city you couldn't
even picture them as military
and when the Ukrainian Army came you
could see real men true Warriors true
causex and that's why the Russians will
lose
okay let's go
press the button
foreign
let's see what we're gonna see
everything will be fine
please from what media
thank you
in the village we made a small stop near
Posada
the zappers are working by the way a
representative of the state emergency
service told us that the sappers from
all over Ukraine are working in
Hearthstone oblast today
this is the most mind area since the
24th of February
thank you
foreign
[Music]
good afternoon glory to Ukraine
Oh Glory to Heroes kids
glory to Heroes you have no idea how
long we've been waiting
it's so nice to see you
there's no connection my phone is as old
as I am there's no communication nothing
but I was walking from the market and I
saw four of our soldiers I fell on my
knees in front of them my child oh
they're so beautiful they're not wearing
Baba clavas they're all in new uniforms
and shaved you know my daughter always
believed that Ukraine would not abandon
her son
thank God
may God give Health to our military
a book God bless all ukrainians we're
waiting and having faith I couldn't calm
down when he said Putin said his quote
who sows the wind uh shall reap the
Whirlwind this is
I think now she has what he wished for
right my child of course may God grant
you good health I'm very very happy as I
see the military you know I can't help
myself I'm an old woman I've lived a
long life but I have a grandson
[Music]
oh she's crying
due to the occasion of the liberation of
her son and neighbor gifted me this tree
and told me to plant it in honor of the
liberation of her son and it will be
called Victory right here I'm already
starting to plant it yes I'll put things
in order a little on the flower bed
because I wasn't willing to do anything
before and now I am
tell us about the day when the Ukrainian
Army entered the city how did the locals
react I'm still crying they were honking
everyone was shouting everyone was
screaming including ourselves it was
marvelous we are so grateful to our
Warriors they're such good lads they are
our Guardian Angels Ukraine's glory and
freedom have not died because we
ukrainians are united by Fate our
enemies will fade like due in the sun
because ukrainians Reign on their land
and don't you damn enemies dare to scare
us or you'll go home in a casket
something like this this is what I feel
yeah and it's gonna be like that you're
great my neighbor uncle arkasha gave it
to me and there he is on the second
floor
you gave us a plant it would be named
victory
his son was liberated from fascists on
13 March 1944.
and from rashes
on the 11th the soldiers were two days
ahead
got it right
yeah but on the 11th of November yeah
yeah November
together
and one more thing there was this man
omnel Chinko
Michael at the market in here son
he is now in Odessa
he's missing hands
he moves on a wheelchair but he managed
to collect
600 000 harivnas
for the Ukrainian Army under occupation
[Music]
I was under occupation
from the 24th of February to the 19th of
September
we came up to him and thanked him we
said you are a hero of Ukraine
and he began to cry
we know him thank you thank you thanks
we know about him Uncle krisha we saw
him and we heard his songs yes we did I
wish you good luck good luck thank you
floor to Ukraine glory to the heroes
probably
[Music]
is
now we are going to meet with the police
department
and the investigators who conduct
criminal cases here
mainly against the Russians
we'll chat and find out what is
happening Here and Now
[Music]
thank you
we bought zaspart attack waffles
waffles are with cacao they cost 100
good evening by the way are you sure not
rubles no yes we just didn't have any
rubles
manufacturer
LLC spartac Republic of
belaruskaya Street 63.
made on the 15th of August 2022 they're
super fresh
[Music]
too bad they hadn't sold out on time
Street three this is a temporary
Detention Facility premises and in fact
it served as a torture chamber as
torture chambers for keeping citizens
how did the Russians choose such places
it is clear
this is a perfect place to keep people
after all this is still a temporary
Detention Center
suspected criminals were kept here and
that means there was a certain
infrastructure for this
but how they used it is another question
because the cells were overcrowded
and people were actually improperly fed
and tortured in various ways so this is
a difficult question
[Music]
um
so far
and we're in one of them right now
these are the rooms where the Russian
military actually lived
there were different branches of the
Armed Forces which periodically rotated
so many have been here to these rooms
did they clean up everything here
if you can call it like that we visited
what's happening there is crazy what's
happening there it's crazy it was also
crazy here glory to the soldiers of the
Russian Federation Zeds Russian Cossacks
will make a demon out of any sucker are
these choices of blood it looks like
blood at least
in this room exactly
torturers were carried out and there
were signs pointing that out traces of
batons on the wall
on this table there was a field
telephone
a kind of dinamo to which wires were
connected these wires were getting
connected to prisoners
to their bodies to various parts
including genitals and an electric
current was passed through their bodies
this is how they were being tortured
they were getting beaten electrocuted
waterboarded and put on gas masks to
block their Airway
the torture methods were diverse and
this is all according to those who
experienced it there were broken bars
here has someone tried to escape from
here
I think it's impossible to escape from
here hardly anyone would have dared
especially after being tortured when
people could barely walk and breathe let
alone run away
what does it say samayas
they drew the coat of arms of Ukraine in
the middle
you see
maybe that's how they see Ukraine and
there on the other side is the Crimean
Tata symbol so I I spent a long time
over here while they were doing some
manipulations with the phone over there
here right
yeah
I could hear someone getting
interrogated in the opposite room so I
was on the right probably as I was in
the so-called pencil case and the person
was interrogated here I could hear a
woman scream this room is called a
pencil case I was sitting here
they put me on the edge and he sat on
the opposite side talking to me they put
tape over my eyes so I couldn't see
anything the woman she was screaming
badly it lasted for a while for more
than 10 minutes several people were
being interrogated at the same time
so so you could hear you could hear
constant screams
throughout days and throughout the
nights I mean endless male and female
screams
where were you kept I was kept on the
second floor
in cell 11.
here's my cell
there were always at least seven people
here
here we were eating everyone had their
own water bottle
but the water was undrinkable which we
collected from the tap
the light was on all day and all night
here we had bunk beds
and the other three people were sleeping
on the floor
did you take turns no no those those who
had already slept in a particular place
stayed there
if a place became free it was given up
voluntarily
if a person was elderly we would free a
place for them
how were you brought in
I was taken in a Renault in a in a
minibus with my eyes covered with tape
and my hands tied with a rope
you know they were solving some some of
their personal issues while driving
around the city
buying some stuff and and then they
brought me they brought me right here
did they try to drive around the city to
confuse you
you know as I understand they were they
were just doing their own business
and when we arrived here as I said
immediately there was brutal violence
they were beating me on the head
beating my head against the wall and
then they put me in a pencil case where
I was sitting
and I heard how they were interrogating
and torturing the girl
who was brought with me
how did they get you
near my house
well the thing is is that the house in
which we lived it was hit by Rockets
we came up to it to see whether our our
windows and apartments were intact or
not
they got suspicious of me because I
didn't spend the night at home when
there was a strike
and that was enough to detain me
someone opened a window
even to just the backyard at night or
during the day
it was mandatory to stand with hands
behind your back
you had to look out the window when they
entered the cell we had to shout glory
to Russia glory to Putin glory to Shogun
almost every day
their workers would come with a stun gun
and demand that we sing the national
anthem of Russia sing it Unison
line by line
is someone stumbled or or whatever they
had to turn around and get hit in the
neck with a shocker the hit was so
powerful that the man fell face down on
the floor then got up
this could continue several times
in the evening they could do a concert
[Music]
it didn't happen to my cell but the
people from another cell were demanded
to sing songs that Russians liked such
as gentlemen's officers you know and
others they handed out what was needed
to be learned to sing in the evening
and we had to clap along if some cell
didn't applaud they could come and
punish everyone who was in that cell
[Music]
it's brutal
they you know they could just hit
somebody on the head just for looking
when they were entering the cell to uh
to distribute food
[Music]
how did you learn the Russian Anthem The
Anthem it had to be learned let's say
you were you were detained in the
evening
you had to learn it by the morning if
you didn't know it they punished anyone
who didn't know it later later they
could punish an entire cell by Banning
the possibility of receding packages
from outside
did your families know you were here
packages were brought on Tuesdays and
Thursdays if people had any relatives
and and they knew about them being here
after after I was released it was my
duty to to bring packages to those who
stayed here
because
there wasn't much left for for the
people that were here
[Music]
for me the most shocking was a story
about the concerts
because in other cities where we filmed
previously
maybe we just phrase a question like
that because we didn't know that this
could be really happening but here for
the first time
we heard that they were forced to
applaud
and the Russians threw concerts and sang
their favorite songs and forced
prisoners to sing them too
it's just unfathomable
well the walls were covered with lyrics
is something incomprehensible
of course
there's
you see
unbelievable
um out of all the deoccupied territories
that we visited
was under occupation the longest
it seems that the Russians partially
managed to establish their Russian World
rules
the year after communicating with our
heroes
and what we saw in those exact torture
chambers the Imperial Narrative of
Russian culture
is very clearly felt
um
as which many already say
um Pushkin and lemon Tov are also
Invaders
and when it's written on the walls in
the torture chambers when people were
forced to memorize
um the poems by ledmintoff
well you know there are people who
advocate for for leaving leadment of in
the Ukrainian school program the same
lemon Tov whose poems are written on the
walls of the torture chamber after this
there's there's absolutely no place for
Russian poets neither in our school
programs and in our life whatsoever
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
position
the Russians detained and tortured me
for 54 days
what did you do before The full-scale
Invasion
before The full-scale Invasion
I was manufacturing furniture
I was a volunteer
a deputy and I worked in a public
organization on the 24th of February at
about six in the morning I heard some
kind of explosions or something I didn't
understand what it was then my mother
came in holding the phone in her hand
crying and saying that the war has
started he got up and thought about what
we had to do we decided we needed to get
some water and go to buy food I stocked
up on food back on the 20th of February
because I had a feeling that something
was going to happen this was when the
Russians recognized the so-called LPR
and DPR and what was next how did the
events unfold in fact rallies began the
Rawlins started in March and on the
first or second of March after the
Russians entered the city at first they
were in the region and in her son the
locals didn't really understand what it
was the territorial defense was
organizing there everyone was making
Molotov cocktails it was the thing to do
but there's Molotov cocktails were never
used
no they weren't the guys did not
understand that it was a regular army
and Cocktails are not effective against
them
in the first week I realized that there
might be some kind of battles around so
I stayed at home I did not go out when
everything became clear rallies began
the Russians did not know what to do
they were stunned they are not used to
such resistance because in Russia there
it is very rare Russians just get
arrested there and here half the city
came out and started fighting against
them they were shooting in the air and
our people were not afraid and we're
still marching at them the guys put a
Ukrainian flag on top of a Russian
armored personnel carrier this photo
traveled across the world
[Music]
[Applause]
let's create a humanitarian Center a
week later the city ran out of food
and I remembered that I had a friend
dimitro holdenovski by the way he is now
defending our borders
as I know he is already in dambas and he
was a farmer he had 100 tons of potatoes
there
they have been a little spoiled already
I called him and said dimitro people are
starving let's distribute potatoes
because not a single car can come or
leave the city
and he gave the potatoes we started
getting it and distributing to the Local
District councils I started streaming
videos and everyone started writing to
me can I get some potatoes we started
Distributing the potatoes and around the
same time we went to the mayor's office
I was led to organize a humanitarian
Center in school number 23. the city
council was still Ukrainian at the time
wasn't it it was still normal yes and we
started feeding people there little by
little local business owners were
bringing us food and we were cooking and
we were still cooking for the military
what is the name of this initiative
there's none we called ourselves glass
container since it was the name of the
location we are still working and now
humanitarian Aid is coming there they
gave us a starlink and set up with a
generator that's how we work
is a originally from dambas
but he moved to hinichisk there he was a
fish inspector
then he stole something there
after that he became a raw food eater
conducted Russian races with flags in
our city
then he went to Latin America
traveled there by motorcycle and there
he was either bitten by mosquitoes as
they say or something like that and he
as I understand it went crazy
in 2014 he started running there with a
portrait of unikovic saying he was a man
from the president
then he went to the police worked in the
security service of Ukraine in 2022 went
to Crimea China and met with some
curators there
we found out about this later
for the first two weeks of the
full-scale invasion he was not in touch
with the Russians in any way as I
understood from his video stream and
then on the 9th of May as far as I
understand he and mercaldo were scamming
Russians
saying that there was practically the
Russian World here and then when the
Russians came but there was nothing like
that here so they forced them to become
collaborators at first saldo was
claiming that he was forced then he
avoided talking about it but later they
became very obvious collaborators
what lesson should we learn from this
today
is there a feeling that her son
residents somehow reflected on this
experience
but not a lot of them
it's necessary to crash such [__]
like and saldo immediately you can't
give them any benefit of the doubt we
need active citizens to unite as Katya
hansuk wrote to crash the Traders
because
as you can see a Russian tank comes
after pushkin's poems and monuments to
Lenin
how did your story unfold later
how were you captured
in 2014 I was part of right sector for a
month and a half and I saw the Russians
started coming up to the guys who were
in right sector
for the first two weeks I was hiding I
saw that the detentions have already
ended
I returned home and no one was touching
me and then they knocked on my door and
conducted a search took out two laptops
a hard drive and flash drives by the way
when they did that I had a phone case
with a print that said who ordered Katya
hanjuk's death the fsp officers found it
and decided to arrest me
my mother asked
and when are you they said we'll talk to
him and he'll come back I return 54 days
later
what now can you personally advise
people who are now coming out of
captivity or returning from torture
rooms
what should they do seek some kind of
psychological support or
you need to take vitamins
and sleep more to recover
y
I've been recovering for about two
months
and now I work with a psychologist
what do you think will happen to her son
next to the region with the city the
whole region is yet to be deoccupied I
think that in a couple more weeks the
Ukrainian Army will push them back
I think that we will also liberate
Crimea before next summer now they will
push back the Russians and everyone will
return to her son
yes when it is pushed back how important
is this Left Bank for the city
well in fact it is not really the city
of haasan on the Left Bank anymore there
are towns of oleschke
yes it's not your son there but those
are people and they need to be liberated
but people often talk about the Left
Bank of hersan as if it is a part of the
city yeah yes it's true those are our
people we need to liberate them we will
not abandon them and the guys are giving
their lives for that why will Russia
suffer a defeat because we are free and
strong the spirit of kazakhs lives in us
thank you
a representative of the partisan
information movement named um yellow
ribbon who goes under the pseudonym
taras agreed to talk to us
and tauras will tell us today
how it all started in the city how they
were working and what the participants
of this movement managed to do it all
started on April 25th we started to
spread info that on the 27th of April we
would organize a rally against the
Harrison People's Republic
we encourage people to come with posters
with postcards and yellow ribbons and we
managed to organize a rally for 500
people this rally was violently crashed
by the FSB officers
you mean the video on the web where
people were shot yeah well it's not that
they were shot they just threw stun
grenades at them there they were getting
stopped by
FSB officers the military police of the
Russian Federation and so on
if we take it in terms of informational
Warfare we strongly boosted the talk
about Carson we showed the atrocities of
the Invaders and I'm absolutely sure
that we prevented them from holding a
referendum quickly
uh our movement gained a very very great
resonance in kerasan
we were urging people to hand out yellow
ribbons and draw yellow ribbons and the
Invaders were Furious
we sent postcards to our people who were
here
this for example is a leaflet against
Russians forcing their passports on
ukrainians
is there something flying
so it's all right it's not our Direction
over here please
why the yellow ribbon it's one of the
colors of our national flag and as you
know it has a really vibrant energy
yellow it's just easier to apply yellow
paint I'm sorry do you know anything
about the yellow ribbon yes what exactly
did you hear it was our partisans and
her son who were working hard and
supporting us and you you're from
kirison right yes we stayed here in
Herson for all these nine months held on
and we're very much waiting to be
liberated by our armed forces of Ukraine
that's cool that's great and let us be
without light without water without
heating but let us be free many thanks
to our Defenders thank you for your
resistance you see that's the effect
they already know about us and that's
awesome 3 000 people we definitely have
up to 3 000 people spreading across the
temporarily occupied territory of
Ukraine I'll tell you the truth we saw a
woman didn't we yeah
and there's a lot of women like that who
also joined in who were gluing something
at night hanging yellow ribbons making
graffiti with the symbol of the
Ukrainian Armed Forces there's a lot of
them and we don't know yet what the real
number is because I assume it's more
than three thousand many activists also
you know they they can't show us the
result of their work so they just keep
on working and we find out about it
later here look a yellow ribbon near the
city council of kerasan you know I
really hope that Mr stremusoff from the
Harrison Regional State Administration
was walking here together with saldo and
saw these yellow ribbons
excuse me have you heard anything about
the yellow ribbon I saw it at the bus
stop in the morning I was traveling in
public transport and people tied up
yellow ribbons and in the morning you
can see that someone was working at
night did it help you in any way maybe
it supported your morale of course this
meant that our guys were somewhere close
we believed that our guys would come our
people were hanging them everywhere on
the streets on the poles
we're now feeling what freedom and
liberty are
we can now calmly walk around the city
eight months of being under occupation
as if an advice we were afraid to walk
around the city no I'm telling the truth
aren't I
we were walking and looking down so that
we wouldn't have to see them
yeah I told you excuse me but I have
sneaked snakes that are black and yellow
over yellow
so you were a partisan
see how many Ukrainian flags are raised
on top of cars now people found them
first they were buried and now they are
raised and when these so-called Russians
liberators came liberators yeah they
liberated us from everything we had to
tie white pieces of clothing to the car
so they wouldn't shoot us yeah people
who had cars attached white ribbons then
they were getting dirty the Russian
world is a dirty white rag
and the Russian flag it's also a dirty
rag
look what people said here they saw the
yellow ribbon for them it was some kind
of Hope how did you react when you heard
the track my Carson by palindrome it's
cool it's it's really awesome
[Music]
child
yeah
I really like that he showed her son as
it is
and in this video there's freedom and
freedom freedom is also the national
idea of ukrainians
it wasn't shallow which they're trying
to impose on us our national idea it's
freedom and it's victory
foreign
[Music]
wow that's great
listen whose work is the portrait of
zelusne I don't know this by the way
it's really cool it took me a bit of
time to realize that it was illusionate
I thought it was Russia that's true both
God and zalusia are with us and that's
really cool
[Music]
guys we just met with Yvonne Yvonne is
also one of the founders of the yellow
ribbon movement
yeah actually they're the heroes of our
time so tell me where are we now and why
uh right now we're at 129 Kulik Street
lived in this building
according to our activists and our local
residents he lived in apartment 48. so
what we're going to do is we're going to
draw a large yellow ribbon on the
entrance so that it also reminds the
locals so that it terrifies Canelo and
the collaborators who remain in the city
let's start
[Music]
friends we can't film as we usually do
our normal stories because the guys are
doing really important work so publicity
is dangerous for them it's a great joy
that they've agreed to talk to us so so
I'm sorry that some shots may be taken
from behind their back and it's not very
aesthetic but it's safer for the guys
watch out there's a curve
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
the last few interviewees have told us
quite a lot about the resistance
and about what we actually focus on
and what we want to show because the
stories of deoccupation are stories
about how people
resisted the occupation
bringing our Victory closer
bringing in the liberation of all our
territories closer including Crimea
which will eventually be liberated and
where we will definitely go to film our
de-occupation series
and we actually had a few conversations
that we aren't able to show
there was one subject who refused to be
shown
we had a very cool conversation with him
um unfortunately
so we can't show this yet in the series
because it was about how traitors were
killed yeah
we filmed a story about house on in two
teams first Karina a producer went and
shot one part of the story
today we had a
big interesting day
time after his Liberation from Russian
occupation
and although the day was busy and we're
tired I personally have very nice
feelings inside
because in fact what we saw was
incredible people we drove along the
streets and people were just waving at
the windows of our buses and drivers
were honking back at them people were
waving flags and I was also struck by
one story
and we went to one of the residential
Courtyards and there was this woman
holding a tree seedling which was given
to her by her neighbor who said plant a
victory in our yard let it grow
a neighbor gave me a juniper tree and
said in honor of such an event plant a
tree almost everyone was crying both men
and women
really sincere
we've already finished filming
and the team were at the beginning we
decided to work this way but in fact we
made such a big episode about Herson and
the diversity of this resistance
because the resistance in her song was
really strong
and I think it will be a very good
release in the end
uh if you like what we do you can
support us on patreon subscribe and be
sure to write a comment on this video
because this will help us to promote it
on YouTube
goodbye everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
against
[Applause]
[Music]